monsieur le ministre la la fin des
travaux de cette commission consiste à
auditionner les ministres des
administration centrale impliquée sur le
les plans écofito sur cette politique
publique qui est dans l'objet Mme de la
commission d'enquête donc je vous
rappelle que cette commission d'enquête
elle consiste à comprendre
l'échec de cette politique publique des
objectifs qu'elle s'est fixés depuis le
Gonel de l'environnement qui ont été
reportés dont on peut se demander
aujourd'hui si malgré le report en fait
on en prend le
chemin et le rapporteur m'a repris
tantôt à juste titre donc je corrige il
s'agit pas de comprendre pour excuser il
s'agit de comprendre pour être plus
intelligent dans les recommandations
pour être plus exigeant plus plus
intelligemment exigeant et pertinent
dans les recommandations fera la
commission pour que ces objectifs soient
atteints à ce titre donc nous
auditionnons les les les ministres des
des quatre principaux ministères
impliqués directement que sont l'
culture évidemment la santé la recherche
et la transition écologique nous avons
reçu la semaine dernière les ministres
Stéphane traver et Guillaume donc je
rappelle que vous-même vous avez été
ministre entre 2018 et 2020 je plus les
dates exactement mais c'est
de
voilà vous avez été min sous le
gouvernement de de Jean Castex entre
juillet 2020 et ma 2022 et nous nous
allons vous demander de nous donner
alors en tant que ministre d'agriculture
vous avez été concerné par beaucoup
d'aspects de cette politique publique le
plan etcito de plus dans sa globalité
surtout en fait vous avez été au cœur
d'un enjeu qui a fait l'objet de pas mal
d'auditions de la commission était
l'articulation entre cette politique
nationale et la PAC donc vous avez
négocié la PAC et mis sur les railes le
PSN même s'il a été finalisé avec votre
successeur donc il est important pour
nous comprendre lors de votre prise de
fonction et ensuite dans l'exercice de
vos fonctions ministérielles la place
qu'a pris etcophyo de plus dans dans vos
priorités dans votre feuille de route la
perception que vous avez eu de sa
cohérence avec les autres objectifs les
autres enjeux de votre portefeuille la
dimension interministérielle est un
point sur lequel la Commission se penche
plus particulièrement quelle a été quel
est l'efficacité
ou ou l'inefficacité de cette de cette
dimension interministérielle euh et je
vais donc vous laisser la parole pour
une une dizaine de minutes pour un topo
liminaire de manière à laisser le temps
au rapporteurs de réagir et ensuite au
membres de la commission de vous vous
poser des questions avant cela je vous
rappelle que cette audition est ouverte
à la presse qu'elle est retransmise en
direct sur le site de l'Assemblée et que
en vertu de l'article 6 du de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958 sur les
le fonctionnement des assemblées
représentatives vous êtes tenu de prêter
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité je vais donc
vous demander de lever la main droite et
de dire je le jure je le jure je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre je vous
laiss la parole merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et Messieurs les les députés
merci beaucoup de me donner l'occasion
de de pouvoir évoquer cela je vois juste
qu'il y a pas de pas de timer donc il
est 16h53 pardon hop
euh le le sujet de de votre commission
d'enquête était évidemment un sujet au
combien important de comprendre les les
causes je vous cite de l'incapacité de
la France à atteint les objectifs
successifs de maîtrise de l'impact des
des produits phytosanitaires et
notamment sur les conditions de
l'exercice d'émissions des autorités
publiques en charge de la santé
sanitaire euh dit autrement l'objectif
que vous êtes assigné dans cette
commission d'enquête si je comprends
bien et de se demander comment faire
pour accélérer la transition les
transition et se donner les moyens de
réduire l'usage des produits
phytosanitaires je voudrais en guise de
propos introductif insister sur un
constat une méthode et une
vision qui évidemment reflète les
actions qui ont été les miennes lorsque
j'ai eu l'honneur d'être à la tête de ce
beau ministère de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation comme vous l'avez dit de
de 2020 à
2022 le constat c'est que à l'évidence
et c'est un constat partager il nous
faut continuer l'effort de réduction de
l'usage des produits phytosanitaires au
regard de l'urgence l'urgence de
biodiversité l'urgence liée au
changement
climatique l'urgence écologique et je
pense qu'il nous faut avoir fort de ce
constat une double boussole une boussole
dite de protection de l'environnement
des consommateurs euh boussole
absolument nécess naire impérieuse
essentielle et une deuxième boussole qui
est une boussole de production comment
arrive-t-on à consilier protection et et
production production en terme
d'autonomie je rappelle que au moment où
on se parle plus de 50 % des fruits et
légumes dans notre pays sont importés
que à peu près 50 % de la viande ça
dépend évidemment des catégories de
viande sont également importé et le plus
souvent avec des produits d'importation
qui ne respectent pas les règles d'usage
que nous fixons à nos à nos
agriculteurs le sujet de production est
lié est lié également et et et le retour
du tragic en Europe avec la guerre menée
par la Russie en Ukraine ma rappelé à
des enjeux de
souveraineté souveraineté alimentaire
souveraineté agronomique et peut-être
même à une question sur lequel j'aurais
plaisir à revenir celle de la mission
nourricière de la France et de l'Europe
vis-à-vis d'un certain nombre de
partenaires à l'international sujet au
combien important alors fort de ce
constat je pense que il nous faut avoir
une méthode une méthode pour réduire en
priorité évidemment les cmr1 puis les
cmr2 euh classification que nous donnons
au aux produits phytosanitaires et et
que vous connaissez cette méthode moi je
voudrais insister sur cinq points qui me
paraissent absolument essentiel le
première la première des méthodes c'est
d'avoir le courage d'affronter la
temporalité et notamment la temporalité
sur les
alternatives je fais partie de ceux qui
considèrent qu' évidemment il ne faut
pas laisser nos agriculteurs sans
solution et que cette question des
alternatives est absolument essentielle
on sait que le courage en politique
c'est d'affronter le temps que c'est
parfois compliqué mais que c'est pas
parce que c'est compliqué qu'il ne faut
pas le faire bien au contraire investir
dans les alternatives c'est absolument
essentiel j'ai vécu de très très près la
question de la jaunice pour les
betterraaves souvenez-vous la loi
d'arrêt des néonicotinoïdes date de 2016
au moment où je prends cette décision
que vous avez voté ici à à l'Assemblée
nationale euh les alternatives
n'existent pas euh on a mis en place ce
fait d'ailleurs ma première élection un
pnri un plan national de recherche pour
trouver des solutions que j'avais doté à
l'époque de 7 millions d'euros et
aujourd'hui euh je ne sais si vous avez
auditionné linraay mais les dernières
déclarations de linraay sur les sujets
euh sont extrême encourageante mettant
en avant un un panel d'alternative qu'il
nous faut encore finaliser parce que le
temps de la recherche en agronomie est
extrêmement
lent les alternatives cela veut dire que
il faut avoir une très forte
méthodologie pour les bâtir typiquement
on connaît en avance un certain nombre
de molécules qui sont listées par la
Commission européenne comme faisant
partie des prochains paquets de
réglementation il est absolument
impérieux que cette liste puisse guider
le travaux de nos recherches qu'elles
soi publiqu ou de nos recherches qu'ell
soient privée il faut anticiper les
alternatives et il faut au-delà de cette
gestion du temps investir massivement
dessus c'est ce que nous avions fait à
la demande du Président de la République
dans le cadre des plans d'investissement
que ce soit le plan de relance d'une
part ou le plan France 2030 d'autre part
il est absolument nécessaire d'affronter
le temps et d'investir dans les
alternatives car sinon c'est trop facile
de dire il suffit d'arrêter ça ne marche
pas comme ça et singulièrement pas quand
on on travaille le vivant comme le font
nos
agriculteur le deuxième question de
méthode c'est que ces méthodes elles
portent évidemment sur les alternatives
euh de produit à produit euh mais elle
porte aussi et c'est fondamental sur
l'agronomie elle-même et je voudrais
insister dessus euh évidemment en tant
que ingénieur agronome j'ai j'ai une
croyance particulière en en l'agronomie
mais l'agronomie est un élément
absolument essentiel dans les
alternatives elle n'est elle est une des
parties ce n'est pas la seule euh mais
que ce soit sur la rotation des cultures
que soit sur la question des ha que soit
sur la question de l'agriculture de
conservation agriculture qui met en cher
que soit sur HVE que soit sur
l'agriculture bio que soit sur
communément appelé l'agriculture
régénérative aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
l'agriculture qui privilégie le sol la
matière organique et qui prend cela
comme boussole euh c'est absolument
essentiel de pouvoir investir euh
également massivement là-dedans la
troisème méthode c'est qu'il y a la
nécessité d'un accompagnement d'un
accompagnement de nos agriculteurs que
ce soit dans le déploiement de ces
alternatives que ce soit dans le
consensus sur le chemin pour atteindre
ces alternatives que ce soit dans dans
le développement euh sur le terrain des
différentes alternatives que nous
aurions pu euh euh trouver et à à ce
titre le plan écofyo les fermes défi que
je sais si chèement attaché à à votre
rapporteur est un élément absolument
essentiel l'accompagnement par le plan
écofito et par les fermes défi est à mes
yeux l'un des éléments les plus
important de cette politique évidemment
il en va de même pour les Chambres
d'agriculture pour les services de
l'État et cette accompagnement est est
très important à ce titre entre
guillemets en entre parenthèses si je
puux dire je pense qu'il y a un vrai
sujet que nous avions établi qui était
un engagement de campagne du président
de la République en 2017 voté en 2018
mise en œuvre en 2021 qui était la
séparation vente conseil
euh qui a qui s'est substitué si je puis
dire au certificat d'économie produits
phytosanitaires débat que nous avions eu
à l'époque j'espère que votre commission
d'enquête évalue euh la différence de
méthode entre cette séparation vente
conseil et ces certificats d'économie
produits phytosanitaires je pense qu'il
est important d'éclairer quelle quelle
est la meilleure des deux alternatives
si je puis dire
euh je pense qu'il faut le faire sur la
base des réalités de terrain mais qu'il
ne faut pas balayer d'un revers de la
main ce que ont été les certificats
d'économie de produits phytosanitaires
et de comprendre parmi ces deux options
quelle est véritablement la la plus
pertinente je n'ai pas les données
aujourd'hui ayant quitté le ministère il
y a plus d'un an et demi maintenant mais
je pense que il est probablement
pertinent que la que votre commission
s'attache dessus le 4è élément de de
méthode absolument essentiel c'est la
valorisation économique euh des
pratiques ainsi considéré du déploiement
des alternatives ainsi mises en place
une alternative c'est de
l'investissement c'est le temps mais
c'était également ça doit également être
euh la valorisation économique je ne
reviens pas sur les lois que nous av
nous avons passé notamment une PPL d'un
excellent député de l'époque aujourd'hui
président de votre commission sur le
partage de la valeur tout au long de la
chaîne de valeur mais évidemment tant
que ces alternatives ne seront pas une
composante de la valeur des produits
agricoles et parce que c'est une chose
de lire çaen est une autre de le faire
dans une rétrocession dans le coût des
choses alors la dynamique sera d'autant
plus dure à mettre en place et je crois
que cette question du prix cette
question de la valeur est absolument
essentielle parce que là aussi il serait
trop facile de ne pas prendre en compte
cette composante économique qui souvent
peut conduire à mettre beaucoup
d'agriculture d'agriculteur pardon dans
des impasses fortes c'est d'autant plus
difficile dans une période d'inflation
on le voit par exemple avec la chute de
consommation des produit bio aujourd'hui
qui est un exemple parmi d'autres mais
on voit à quel point cette valeur de la
prise ente compte des de l'environnement
que soit le carbone ou que soit la
biodiversité dans le coût et la valeur
des produits agricoles est un élément
absolument essentiel enfin 5ème point de
méthode je pense que l'proche filière
est absolument essentielle je vis à ce
titre juste vous donner un exemple on
dit vous vous le savez par cœur mais le
ce qui impose le plus un certain nombre
de traitements notamment les fongicide
c'est le manque de diversité des
essences dans un champ typiquement une
une monoculture de blé c'est-à-dire un
champ avec une seule variété de de blé
pendant des années ce sont les meuniers
qui ont imposé aux agriculteurs d'avoir
une seule variété de blé dans leur champ
parce que les meuniers qui ensuite font
la composition de la farine en utilisant
plein de variétés de blé différentes
voulez absolument avoir des blés pures
arrivant dans leurs différents silos il
y a un groupe qui en 2017 a dit en fait
on va changer de technique au lieu de
faire le mélange des blés dans les silos
dans les meneries on va faire le mélange
de blé directement dans les champs ils
ont créé une variété de blé à planter
cette variété de blé a permis de limiter
significativement l'utilisation de
produits notamment de fongicide dans les
champs ce que je veux dire par là c'est
quand on on ne fait que passer le mytigr
aux agriculteurs on voit bien qu'on met
des gens dans l'impasse quand on se
responsabilise au niveau d'une filière
de l'amont à laav on voit bien que ça
peut aller beaucoup plus vite enfin dans
dans les 3 minutes qui me reste je
voudrais insister sur un dernier point
important qui est la vision qui est la
mienne qui a été la mienne et qui je
crois restera la mienne si si je reste
cohérent ce que ce que j'espère euh
vis-à-vis de ces C ce sujet et comment
accélérer je pense qu'il y a deux choses
absolument essentielles au-delà de du
constat et de la méthode que que que
j'évoqué la première des choses c'est
qu'il est impérieux d'investir
massivement et de croire dans ce que
j'avais qualifié de 3è révolution
agricole le monde agricole a été
confronté à une première évolution c'est
le machinisme au sortir de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale bref la mécanisation le
tracteur avec certaines conséquences euh
notamment la question de de du
regroupement des parcelles euh des ha
euh le la terre adore les ha les
tracteurs un peu moins
euh cette révolution agricole elle était
absolument nécessaire euh à l'époque le
la France et l'Europe avaient faim et il
fallait produire beaucoup plus euh euh
beaucoup plus fortement puis la deuxème
révolution agricole l' grrosochimie dans
les années 70 80 puis au début des
années 2000 une remise en cause de cette
2e révolution agricole en demandant non
plus de produire mais de produire et de
protéger et depuis lors cette deuxème
révolution agricole fait la course à la
réduction des pesticides vous l'aurez
compris chose absolument nécessaire et
une vision que que je
partage avec la méthode que j'évoqué
mais il me semble qu'aujourd'hui il faut
passer à une troisème révolution
agricole qui est fondée sur le num
numérique la robotique la génétique et
le biocontrôle le numérique parce que
c'est ce qui permet de faire les choses
avec beaucoup plus de précision que ce
soit sur les doses d'engrais les doses
de produits les d'intran mais également
les quantités d'eau utilisées la
robotique parce que sur les alternatives
vous parlez beaucoup en ce moment du du
glyphosate vous m'aveiez déjà entendu le
dire le jour où véritablement un
substitut au glyphosate existera c'est
quand on acceptera d'avoir des des
robots qui dans les champs iront
désherber ces champs on sait bien que la
solution elle viendra de là parce que il
faut privilégier une agriculture qui ne
la Bour pas pour pouvoir conserver le
carbone au sein de du sol mais ne pas la
bourer sans déerber et quelque chose sur
lequel il n'existe pas modulo quelques
tentative d'alternative soutenable à
l'heure où on se parle or la robotique
permettra de le faire la troisième
volete c'est la génétique la génétique
avec l'accélération la sélection
végétal notamment en assumant les
nouvelles techniques qui doivent être
encadré et je salue des évolutions y
compris au niveau de la Commission
européenne sur le sujet et enfin le
biocontrôle parce que nous restons dans
une chaîne alimentaire où rien de mieux
qu'un insecte qui vient tuer un autre
insecte ravageur de culture première
vision donc croire dans cette 3isè
révolution agricole et investir
massivement dessus c'est elle qui nous
permettra d'aller production et
protection Enfin le de deè élément qui à
mes yeux est essentiel c'est d'avoir le
courage d'affronter les politiques
commerciales aujourd'hui je suis un
fervant défenseur des Clos miroir mais
alors vraiment un très grand défenseur
des clauses miroir je pense
qu'aujourd'hui nos théories commerciales
notamment à l'OMC restent fondé sur les
théories de Ricardo des avantages
comparatifs et on ne peut pas lui en
vouloir c'était il y a près de de
siècles si mon mes calculs sont bons à
l'époque Ricardo parle des avantages
comparatifs le sujet de l'environnement
n'est pas prise en compte et donc il n'a
pas pu mettre une virgule en disant sauf
si ses avantages comparatifs étaient
fondés sur des externalités négatives
c'est-à-dire de la déforestation ici ou
ou de la dégradation de l'environnement
là-bas mais tant que nous n'irons pas
plus loin au niveau européens sur les
clauses miroir ça veut dire que nous
acceptons d'importer dans notre pays des
choses que nous n'acceptons pas de
produire nous-mêmes et là ça n'est pas
possible ce n'est pas possible
d'accélérer massivement dans ce cas tant
qu'on accepte de d'un apporter des
noisettes utilisées avec des
néonicotinoïdes aériens par exemple en
Turquie de Turquie pardon produit que
nous avons interdit en France dans son
dans son utilisation et bien on met en
difficulté drastiquement nos producteurs
tant qu'on accepte d'importer du poulet
fait avec des hormones de protection des
antibiotique pardon de
protection massif et bien on crée des
concurrences absolument déloyales et on
on met même en place des risques
environnementaux
absolument énormes que ce soit sur de la
biorésistance ou que ce soit de la
déforestation associée voilà monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés
quelques élément de réflexion si je puis
dire et de retour d'expérience que je
voulais partager avec vous merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre pour cette
introduction très structuré très clair
monsieur le rapporteur je vous laisse
réagir si je confirme c'est structuré
c'est clair merci Monsieur le Ministre
on est heureux de vous entendre et
dialoguer avec vous on va passer aux
travaux au travaux pratiques
euh quand vous êtes arrivé au enfin tout
de suite question de méthode on a on a
une bonne heure de on a une heure devant
nous monsieur le
Président une petite heure une petite
heure moi j'ai j'ai j'ai énormément de
questions vous imaginez bien quoi vous
êtes un des derniers ministres en
exercice bon on va voir Marc Phen mais
c'est c'est vous qui avez été sur la
plus longue durée dans dans la période
récente euh et les collègues sont
nombreux avec une impétence équivalente
à la mienne donc je vais prendre 20
minutes mais ça veut dire que sur une
dizaine de questions vous connaissez la
règle il faut qu'on arrive à tenir
j'attends nous comptons sur vous quand
vous êtes arrivé vous avez fait le vous
avez fait le point sur sur
écofyo succéd à DJ Guillaume on était
sur écofyo 2
euh qu'est-ce que vous vous êtes dit
franchement ça marchait pas quoi et ça
marche toujours pas hein c'est voilà
c'est pour quelqu'un qui est exigeant
une culture du résultat comme vous vous
êtes pas dit mais quel gâchie quoi en
terme de politique publique c'est ça
marche pas
donc toutes les discussions on les a eu
hein l'objectif était trop haut c'est la
faute à l'autre ministère c'est la faute
au marché c'est la faute à l'étranger
enfin bon mais mais bon votre première
réflexion c'est c'est quoi et qu'est-ce
que vous allez changer parce qu'après
dans quand on va regarder ce que vous
avez pris comme initiative on est un peu
dubitative donc vous allez nous
expliquer pourquoi vous avez pris telle
ou telle décision pourquoi vous l'avez
pas pris mais quel constat vous faites
déjà au
départ ah
euh moi moi je crois dans cette
politique je pense que ecofito a en fait
moi je je crois en politiques qui sont
fondés sur une vision une méthode
d'ailleurs je vous l'ai montrer dans mon
propos introductif etcofito c'est une
vision une méthode euh donc j'y crois je
ce que je crois beaucoup dans ecofito
c'est en plus la preuve par l'exemple
euh je le disais tout à l'heure c'est
l'accompagnement crois beaucoup au
réseau des fermes défi et et je crois
beaucoup dans sa structuration après sur
les objectifs des cofito euh au-delà
donc de la méthode qui encore une fois
est à mes yeux vraiment la bonne méthode
sur les objectifs des cofyau de de
réduction
euh je je pense que
cela s'inscrit dans une politique qui
doit évidemment être plus globale
c'est-à-dire que tant que
on n'est pas dans
une et c'est ce que je me suis attché à
faire tout au long de de de de mon de ma
présence au sein du ministère mais tant
qu'on n'est pas dans une politique qui
arrive à investir massivement dans les
alternative à investir massivement dans
l'agronomie à investir massivement avec
ce courage d'affronter au niveau
international les distorsions de
concurrence qu'elle soit d'ailleurs au
niveau européen ou à travers le monde on
a
des bâtons dans les roues de la
dynamique essayer d'être insufflé par
écofito qui rend d'autant plus difficile
l'atteinte des projets portés par
ecofito donc je je crois dans cette
politique je crois dans sa méthode je
pense qu'il que c'est un des éléments
d'un plan global d'une politique globale
qui a été celle que j'ai essayé de
porter donc fait le constat que vos
prédécesseurs n'avent pas la bonne
méthode c'est pas c'est pas ce que j'ai
dit monsieur le rapporteur et puis je je
suis pas là pour juger ce que font mes
on fait mes prédécesseur ce que je dis
c'est que moi quand je suis arrivé dès
mon discours d'ailleurs de passation je
dis qu'on on n pas à ce moment là on on
n pas encore le début de la catastrophe
de la guerre russe en Ukraine je je sur
le Peron du ministère je viens d'être
nommé je dis on a un sujet c'est la
souveraineté et cette souveraineté elle
passe par la capacité de produire mais
de protéger la souveraineté c'est pas
que d'avoir la plus grande quantité
possible c'est d'avoir la plus grande
quantité possible de manière durable
donc de produire et de protéger et tout
ce que j'ai tenté de mettre en œuvre
ensuite était fidèle à cette vision et
dans le cadre de de de la la jambe de
protection parce qu'encore une fois vous
m'avez entendu le dire quand j'étais
ministre et ce que je viens de vous dire
lors de de mes propos dans cette dans
cette
sur cette jambe de la protection je
considère que cofito est un élément
essentiel je considère que
l'investissement est un élément
essentiel je considère que la politique
internationale est un élément essentiel
et que c'est ce tout qui permettra
d'accélérer ce que je ne crois pas enfin
ce que je crois pardon c'est que
l'accélération elle ne pourra pas venir
que de la politique nationale si on y
associe pas une politique internationale
hyper ambitieuse on on on on n'y
arrivera pas dans les temps imp parti
alors on va parler de la politique
internationale de beaucoup de choses
mais parlons de ce qui relève
directement de votre ministère vous avez
notamment vous héritez d'un d'un réseau
défi qui est passé de de 2000 à 3000
fermes dans à partir du plan ecofito 2
hein et on est au début des CI de 2 plus
et vous prenez la décision de ramener le
le réseau de 3000 à 2000 fermes c'est
pour le moins
paradoxal je peux pas j'ai pas en
tête les chiffres et ce passage monsieur
le rapporteur je peux pas je peux j'ai
pas en tête en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que moi je crois beaucoup au ferme
au ferme défi comme je vous l'ai dit
j'ai pas en tête et vous m'en excuserez
l'ensemble des des points budgétaires et
qu'est-ce qui est passé de de quoi à
quoi en tout cas ce ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que moi je crois beaucoup au
ferme desfi pas vous n'avez pas le
souvenir de cette décision et pourtant
on on a on a auditionné longuement le le
réseau desfi il nous explique que dans
la période où vous êtes ministre alors
pe une décision d' Guillaume avec un
effet retard je ne sais pas je
je vous êtes sous cerment et je ne doute
pas une seconde de votre sincérité mais
en tout cas permettez-moi de pointer la
contradiction vous avez affirmé cette
acte de foi dans un dispositif que je
chéris également vous le
savez on voit la la contribution de du
réseau des filles hein c'est la
démonstration qu'on peut maintenir la
production à laquelle vous êtes attaché
nous y sommes tous attachés ici la
souverainé c'est la production on peut
maintenir le revenu des agriculteurs et
baisser de 37 % sur les rult sur 10 ans
c'est 37 % donc c'est un démonstrateur
un Living Lab grandeur de nature bon
formidable sous votre ministère il passe
de 3000 à 2000 donc c'est quelque chose
qui relève de la DG mais que vous n'avez
arbitre que vous n'arbitrez pas
d'accord euh à la fin moi j'arbiterit
tout et surtout que c'est des
amendements euh qui relèvent de loi de
finance dans le cadre de des budgets
qu'on attribu à ecofito puis sur le
déploiement dans les budgets impartis
dans sa ventilation si ma mémoire est
bonne donc à la fin moi je toutes les
décisions puisque je ne suis pas de ceux
euh qui qui qui considèrent que
l'administration pilote un ministère
donc j'assume absolument tout en vche je
ne pourrais pas vous dire et je n'ai et
et et je n'ai pas mémoire je vous prie
bien vouloir m'en excuser à titre
personnel j'ai j'ai fait un choix il y a
maintenant un an et demi donc voilà j'ai
j'ai pas replongé je n'ai même pas accès
à T tous ces documents maintenant euh
mais encore une fois je peux je pe pas
vous le dire plus plus précisément mais
plus sincèrement je crois beaucoup dans
les fermes des fich vous les dit
d'ailleurs en propos
introductif d'où le le paradoxe que je
voulais lever bon très bien l'autre
grande proposition de ecofuto 2 inspiré
par un rapport que vous connaissez que
j'avais donné rendu au Premier ministre
c'était de déployer 30000 fermes
justement accroché à ces autour de
chaque ferme défi on avait 10 fermes qui
s'engageaient dans une transition
agroécologique donc on massifiait et la
grande difficulté ce qu'on a observé
c'est le continuum recherche
développement grâce notamment notamment
à des initiatives que vous avez initié
ou poursuivi il y a de plus en plus de
solutions mais elle n'arrive pas dans
les fermes bon n'arrive pas dans les
fermes donc là l'idée de la ferme réseau
30000 fermes c'est un petit peu le
Triangle des Bermudes là on sait pas ce
qu'il est devenu donc on a interrogé
votre prédécesseur il sait pas trop la
PCA ils savent pas trop on n' pas de
données chiffrées c'est fou c'est qu'on
décide publiquement dans un plan écofit
2 de faire 30000 3000 fermes et 30000 de
déploiement ça ne se fait pas et
personne n'est capable de l'expliquer
est-ce que vous avez souvenir d'une
politique de déploiement de 30000 fermes
ou alors il fallait pas l'écrire mais si
on l'a écrit et qu'on l'a décidé vootter
et affirmeré dans des plans écofuto 2
publiquement et cetera et tout dans la
réalité ça ne se fait pas on ararrive
même pas à avoir le chiffre de de ce qui
s'est fait ça
ça ça vous dit quelque chose bah il
faudrait que vous faudrait que vous là
pour le coup vous demandiez au ministère
les chiffres exacts que je n'ai pas sur
le
déploiement des solutions sur le terrain
euh ce qui est sûr moi ce qui m'a
beaucoup marqué quand je suis arrivé
c'est que et et ce que je je dis vaut
pour les institut public et les
instituts privés mais sur le volet
institut public c'est-à-dire l'ineray je
me souviens très bien de ce moment où
l'ineray me présente sa
stratégie de travail sur les produits
sur lesquels il il souhaite travailler
sur le plan de charge qui souhaite
travailler et qu'on me remet ce plan de
charge en me disant voilà ce qui va être
le plan de charge de l'ineray et à ce
moment-là j'arrête la chose en disant
pas comme ça qu'on va
fonctionner ce qui est très important
c'est que nous puissions nous indiquer à
liner ce qui doit être les priorités et
chose que j'ai évoqué à de multiples
reprises avec lin Ray ça m'a toujours
surpris à quel point les agriculteurs ne
parlaient pas plus des instituts de
recherche notamment de lineray sur le
terrain et et et pour moi quand les
agriculteurs ne parlent pas de lin Ray
sur le terrain c'est que
l'accompagnement sur ces alternative
dans un travail transversal sur ce volet
de travail transversal n'est pas
suffisant quand je dis ça je salue
profondément et et et j'aime
profondément l'inraay je dis ça sur la
complémentarité entre les travaux de
notre institut de recherche et les
besoins exprimés par les agriculteurs
sur le terrain quant au 30000 et le
chiffre précis faudrait que vous
demander au service du du du ministère
j'ai pas
l'information très bien l'autre l'autre
grand moteur qui a inventé à partir de
2000 17 c'est la séparation du conseil
et de la vente et là je vais je vais
vous rendre hommage sur votre honnêteté
et votre lucidité c'est une dernière
réunion de la commission des affaires
économiques une bonne ambiance et chacun
s'exprime vos louanges vous critiques
enfin c'est un beau bilan vous faites
c'est je sou d'une belle réunion et je
vous interroge et je vous dis je vous
interroge sur ce cette séparation du
conseiller de la vente et vous dites
très clairement c'est pas ce qu'on a
fait de mieux ça mériterait d'être
évalué dans un travail parlementaire bah
c'est ce que nous sommes en train de
faire he c'est bon donc vous aviez
l'intuition dès votre prise de
responsabilité que c'était pas l'idée du
siècle d'accord on l'a qualifié de
fausse bonne idée sur le résultat est
plutôt catastrophique hein c'est c'est
plutôt pire qu'avant est-ce que vous en
aviez la conscience à ce moment-là j'en
ai je je dirais pas que c'est une enfin
je sais pas s'il faut qualifier de
l'intuition mais en tout cas c'est une
interrogation au moment où je vous le
dis euh et d'ailleurs que j'ai repris
dans mes propos introductifs
euh c'est c'est pas
le c'est pas la séparation enfin la
séparation Vantre conseil sur le
principe tout le monde est pour
c'est assez logique que le conseiller ne
doit pas être vendeur bon la question
c'est l'alternative et cette séparation
vendre conseil c'est fait en
substitution des certificats d'économie
de produits phytosanitaires et mon
questionnement porte sur quelle est la
meilleure des deux alternatives et et
mon intuition même ma certitude que
j'évoque à cette époque et que je vous
redis en propos intraductif c'est que je
pense qu'il faut étudier le point après
je n'ai aucun aucun élément
aujourd'hui absolument aucun élément
aujourd'hui pour vous dire il de manière
assurée il faut aller là ou là mais j'ai
l'intuition que la question est
pertinente de comparer les deux et et et
je suis très content que vous le vous le
Facier dans la commission pense qu'il ne
faut avoir aucun dogmatisme dessus ça
peut paraître super sur le papier mais
enfin s'il y a une s'il y a une solution
qui est encore plus pertinente bah
faisons la solution la plus la plus
pertinente que vous l'évaluez me semble
le très bien oui on l'a fait avec votre
prédécesseur qui avec beaucoup de
courage avec lucidité à entendu comme
moi une mission flash ensemble on a
rendu notre copie elle sera intégrée
bien sûr à cette commission d'enquête on
en fera une débrique de la commission
d'enquête je crois que aujourd'hui ça
fait consensus je juste puisque vous
êtes très proche du président de la
République c'est c'est une idée des
présidentielles et c'est la leçon sur
sur les sur les politiques publiques et
le rôle des des campagnes électoral
c'est je je me permets une hypothèse et
en toute en toute dans un esprit de
coopération à chercher à mieux faire
c'est typiquement une idée qui a un
effet marketing important c'est un
signal écologique on va on va assaignir
le le marché on va aller vers plus
d'écologie en S Paron conseil et la
vente après au moment de la mise en
œuvre il faut absolument aller au bout
de cette idée et on distingue pas la fin
et les moyens quoi la fin est louable il
faut travailler sur ce sujet mais c'est
le moyen qui devient un objectif
politique à mettre en œuvre quoi qu'il
en coûte il en coûte très cher
aujourd'hui on a perdu certainement
plusieurs années sur le déploiement des
solutions intelligentes en se privant
des CPP à ce moment-là euh donc c'est
pour moi est-ce qu'on peut tirer une
leçon que quand on fait une campagne
présidentielle on doit donner des
principes un récit mais il faut se
garder de faire des promesses sur des
des mises en œuvre de moyens qui à
l'expérience du terrain et dans
l'hémicycle NT quelques experts à mettre
en garde très fortement le ministre de
l'riculture en disant les cops tout le
monde nous le dit les chambres disent
c'est pas la bonne solution on va se
planter on va perdre des années on va
perdre perdre un moyen crucial sur des
questions économiques écologiques et de
santé publique majeur quoi et pourtant
on le met en œuvre est-ce qu'il y a des
leçons à tirer pour demain d'autres
campagnes présidentielles sous d'autres
cieux moi je dirais qu'il y a surtout le
fonctionnement du Parlement qui doit
marcher dans sa complétude je veux dire
cette séparation elle a été votée par le
Parlement était voté par le
Parlement que le Parlement ensuite
audite la chose dans son travail de
contrôle bah c'est la meilleure des
choses possibles après relatif au aux
engagements dans une campagne
présidentielle je faisais partie de
l'équipe de campagne et on peut on peut
on on pense de bonne fois que c'est une
bonne solution euh d'ailleurs je dois le
dire qui à bino peut se dire en fait les
CEPP c'est bien mieux que la séparation
vent conseil intuitivement la séparation
vant conseil euh est semble très
pertinente qui abinitio peut dire euh
non assurément la CEPP c'est beaucoup
mieux que la séparation vant de conseil
c'est c'est c'est relativement technique
euh comme sujet et et et ça vaut le
c'est c'est je comprends complètement et
moi le premier qu'on puisse croire dans
la séparation V conseil après je pense
que c'est de bonnes politiques vraiment
de bonnes politique et c'est d'ailleurs
la grandeur de la politique que dès lors
qu'on met en place quelque chose que
c'est voté que ça aille jusqu'au bout
c'est tout à fait normal mais qu'une
fois que c'est mise en place qu'on fait
pass l'évaluation sans attendre 10 ans
euh qu'on remette l'ouvrage sur le
métier pour se dire est-ce que oui ou
non et d'ailleurs que le Parlement s'en
saisisse dans ses missions de conseil de
contrôle pardon conformément à au rôle
du Parlement moi je trouve ça de très
très très bonne politiqu
euh on a même pu le faire sur la loi
égalim si vous voyez ce que je veux dire
euh on a remis l'ouvrage sur le métier
très rapidement j'ai toujours dit ça moi
je suis convaincu que que voilà on fait
des choses on peut se tromper il faut AC
faut accepter de de de de enfin faut
l'accepter dès lors que tout de suite on
a le courage de corriger encore une fois
sur séparation vente conseil versus CEPP
je n'ai aucun élément qui
aujourd'hui n conduit à dire évidemment
que c'était pas bien il faut mieux faire
ça ou vis ver ça j'ai l'intuition que la
question est extrêmement pertinente et à
l'époque je disais ce serait très bien
que la l'assemblée
puisse se pencher sur le sujet lors de
la réunion don vous faisiez mention
monsieur le rapporteur et et je je
trouve que c'est très bien que ça ça
soit fait le Parlement s'exprime par un
recours au Conseil d'État qui sur le
fond juge qu'effectivement il a trom
pris du de la délibération du Parlement
puisque on fait semblant de maintenir
les CPPP mais de fait le décret va les
annuler mais il est il est annulé sur la
forme et puis je dis quand même on
construit avec quasiment le même état
d'esprit que celui qui le votre une
politique avec Stéphane Lefol et la
peine mise en route qu'une promesse
présidentielle via battre les cartes et
on repart à zéro et on perd 5 ans je
voulais juste dire on pourrait aussi
peut-être travailler autrement et
capitaliser sur ce qui a été fait
précédemment etessayer de se mettre dans
desuités il y a toute l'espect de
communication qui peut nuire au bien de
la continuité des des politiques
publiques je je je dis juste sur ce
sujet mais je vais le clore parce que
j'en ai un autre vous vous vous
travaillez avec le le préfet Bich qui
est délégué interministériel il transmet
il transmet on l' l'audition du du
préfet Bich a été pour nous édifiante il
nous dit pour qu'il ait pour qu'il y ait
une politique interministéri pour qu'il
ait un délégué interministériel encore
faut-il qu'il y ait une politique
interministérielle bon c'est terrible
bon à un moment donné le préfet Bich on
est en juillet 2020 vous êtes au
responsabilité il y a pas d'erreur sur
la
chronologie
si ça dépend du
jour puisque j'ai été nommé en juillet
2020 si ma mémoire est
bonne voilà préfet Bich en juillet j'ai
pas plus de précision dans les notes qui
sont à ma disposition en juillet 2020 on
pourra rechercher le jour le préfet Bich
vos alert sur le fait que les fonds
écofitau sont trop éclatés géré ici par
les agences et géré par toute une une
comitologie et un ensemble
d'institutions qui nuisent à son
efficacité et il demande il vous suggère
àce qu'on recentre ces crédits et qu'on
puisse en disposer comme une armée en
marche avec un commandement et cetera
bon et c'est vrai hein pour avoir
analysé décortiqué on l'a fait à nouveau
là mais les rapports les rapports remis
au ministrees sont terribles on a rien à
rajouter enfin moi je vous le dis le
rapporteur ne rajoutera rien au rapport
des inspections qui ont été fait et qui
sont calamiteux sur l'usage et la
performance des fonds publics on a rien
à rajouter on va les reprendre t quel
qui vous êtes alerté en juillet 2020 al
vous venez d'arriver vous avez d'autres
préoccupations je j'entends hein mais
clairement le haut fonctionnaire chargé
de mettre en œuvre la politique vous dit
on peut pas continuer avec cette
dispersion cette organisation entre les
ministères qui fonctionnent mal
l'interministérialité fonctionne pas ils
faut un commandement et il faut qu'il
dispose des crédits disponibles que
répondez-vous que évidemment il faut de
l'interministèri
interministérialité que ce que vous
dites et
et d'autant plus si
les inspection l'ont l'ont mise en avant
et est probablement très juste euh et
plus on arrive à condenser sur un
certain nombre de sujets mieux c'est
euh c'est c'est souvent une phrase qui
est très facile à prononcer qui est
beaucoup plus dure à mettre en œuvre
parce que on a tous payé pour voir de se
dire tiens on va supprimer tel et telle
et telle et telle ligne je suis pas sûr
que même vous monsieur rapporteur
m'auriez pas appelé à cette époque en me
disant ouais non mais telle ligne c'est
vraiment pas la bonne à supprimer bah je
vais supprimer telle autre ligne ah oui
mais c'est pas non plus la bonne ligne à
supprimer et cetera et cetera si si ce
que je veux dire donc c'est c'est
évident qu'il faut concentrer les moyens
moi je pense que c'est c'est un peu ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure sur
l'inraay et encore une fois je le dis
avec un immense respect et et et une un
profond soutien à linraay mais de
manière générale je pense qu'il est
important que une vision et des
priorités soi exprimé par les politique
et que cette vision et et ses priorités
se déclineent ensuite partout dans les
champs exercice alors c'est compliqué
parce que quand vous êtes un institut de
recherche vous avez la liberté du
chercheur et heureusement qu'elle est là
cette liberté du
chercheur quand vous
êtes à la tête d'une autorité vous avez
la la la pleinee indépendance de cette
autorité donc évidemment c'est c'est
parfois compliqué de de se focaliser sur
quelques priorité je pense qu'il faut le
faire une fois que j'ai dit ça sur le
volet intermin ministérialité oui ces
politiques sont des sujets de parfois de
tension entre les ministères parfois et
et et c'est bien normal si si je puis
dire euh c'est c'est d'ailleurs même
pour ça
que que il y a un Premier ministre qui
est là pour arbitrer les désaccords
entre les différents
ministres c'est c'est peut-être même
aussi pour ça que aujourd'hui il y a un
secrétaire général à l'environnement qui
avec un petit clin d'œil à ce que vous
avez dit sur votre phrase précédente a
été annoncé dans la campagne
présidentielle de 2022
euh parce que probablement il faut queil
y ait cette vision et qu'il ait ce ce
partage de vision par
tous mais c'est mais c'est parfois
compliqué on
va et moi je crois beaucoup que le fait
d'avoir des priorités et d'avoir des des
raisons enfin de de mettre la raison
dans tout ça permet cette
interministérialité de manière plus plus
forte
j'ajoute juste euh un point qui me
paraît je sais pas si vous allez vous
prononcer dessus mais qui plutôt une
alerte je pense moi j'aiété marqué en
tant que ministre de l'Agriculture à peu
près toutes les décisions que je prenais
étaient porté en justice à peu près
enfin quand je dis tout j'exagère mais
nombre de décisions qu'on peut prendre
sont porté en en justice devant le
tribunal administratif parfois je me
souviens même d'une foire aux questions
qui était porter devant un tribunal
administratif en parallèle beaucoup des
décisions que je prenais s'appuyent sur
les travaux de lanè
autorité avec un statut
singulier dont les décisions s'imposent
enfin les décisions ne peuvent être les
décisions relèvent de l'ANS et et et et
uniquement de l'ANS donc autorité
indépendante mais avec un statut
d'autorité indépendante qui n'est pas
exactement celui des Aï si je si je si
ma lecture juridique est bonne bref ce
que je veux dire c'est que vous avez
d'un côté des décisions qui sont très
souvent porté en justice de l'autre côté
les autorités indépendantes qui émettent
des avis mais des
avis extrêmement précis circonstanciés
et cetera aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit
c'est que beaucoup des décisions qu'on
peut prendre politiquement
parlant quand elles sont porté au
tribunal administratif le le juge se
fonde beaucoup sur la décision de
l'autorité
indépendante la décision de l'autorité
indépendante la place du de la décision
politique et donc de la priorité
politique dans tout ça est une vraie
question c'est compliqué comme débat
parce que moi je suis un un immense
démocrate je je je crois que la justice
est le pilier de notre République et je
suis profondément un ingénieur et je
suis un amoureux de la science donc la
justice et et la science c'est pour moi
les deux piliers enfin deux des piliers
les plus importants de ce que je suis de
comment je raisonne de ce que je fais et
cetera la place de la priorité de la
décision politique dans tout ça est une
vraie question une vraie question et je
pense qu'il faut l'aborder à un moment
ou un autre il faut avoir le courage de
l'aborder parce que c'est pas
évident sur des réponses très courtes
parce que je je vais j'ai épuisé mon
temps et je sens l'impatience des des
collègues euh vos derniers propos je
rebondis est-ce que vous pensez il y a
eu un doute sur l'intention du
gouvernement est-ce que est-ce qu'il
faut qu'il faut revenir sur la loi de
2014 et les prérogatives données à l'an
en matière
d'interdiction pardon je j'ai pas assez
d'éléments pour le dire ce que je en
tout cas je pense qu'il y a un point
c'est
euh quand il y a des quand il y a des je
vais vous donner un exemple
euh on a euh certains d'entre eu d'ici
long on a euh des casades de de
bruxellos qui apparaissent et donc on a
des sujets de la brucellose vous savez
cette maladie qui peut se retrouver dans
le porté par des vaches laitières qui
passent se retrouver dans le lait qui se
retrouve ensuite dans le roblochon
bruselo est lié notamment au bouquetin
et donc il faut avoir des politiques euh
de peuplement des Boutins c'est-à-dire
de de de limiter je je suis amené à
prendre des décisions sur le peuplement
des Boutin et donc des décisions
d'élimination d'un certain nombre de
bouquetins pour éviter la prolifération
de la bruxellose tribunal administratif
est saisi et déboute euh les décisions
que j'ai pu prendre sur la base de
d'avis scientifique ou autre deuxième
exemple quand on prend les décisions sur
un certain nombre de prolongation de
molécules parce qu'on se dit que sur ce
sujet précis il en va de la souveraineté
de notre pays euh que si on ne le fait
pas on peut avoir des des problèmes
d'approvisionnement la vie scientifique
n'est pourtant pas forcément dans ce
sens décision portée devant le tribunal
administratif tribunal administratif qui
qui se fonde sur la en partie pas que
sur la décision sur la pardon laave
scientifique qui déboute l'avis que je
peux rendre euh des exemples comme ça où
à la fin des fins les positions
politiques que nous pouvons prendre pour
une finalité qu'elle soit celle de la
souveraineté celle de la protection du
consommateur celle de l'opportunité non
pas l'opportunité politique au sens
l'intérêt politique l'opportunité au
sens la souveraineté la protection du
consommateur et cetera mais qui donc
n'est n'est pas conforme si je puux dire
ou ou 100 % conforme devrais-je dire
avec euh l' vie
scientifique euh pourtant élément
central de la décision du tribunal
administratif ce point-là ce point-là il
me semble qu'il est important qu'on en
ait tous conscience parce que le poids
de la décision politique dans tout ça
est important en gros c'était aussi l'un
des enseignements de la gestion de la
crise covid souvenez-vous certains
disait que pendant la crise covid le la
la responsabilité de la décision
politique
euh était remis au devant de la scène je
pense que c'est vrai et je pense que ce
débatl il est important alors est-ce que
revoir la loi de 2014 est un des
éléments qui permet d'ouvrir ce débat je
pourrais pas le dire j'ai pas le texte
sous les yeux je suis pas suffisamment
compétent et j'ai conscience que c'est
très dur ce que je dis en terme de et je
voudrais vraiment pas que ce soit mal
interprété hein je dis ça dans un esprit
profondément constructif je suis un
immense
croyant que la justice est le le pilier
de notre démocratie de la République et
un immense croyant dans la science on
qualifie souvent de beaucoup trop born
scientifique avec mon bon côté ingénieur
donc je mais je pense que entre les deux
le choix politique qui peut-être amené
par des considérations de souveraineté
des considérations de de protection
autre que celle étudiée par la dite
agence est un élément central de notre
vie démocratique
oui trois questions mais je je je je
suis sûr que que qu' reste peut-être je
les poserai à la fin mais elles peuvent
également transpirer et et sucer des
réponses dans dans cell que vont poser
nos collègues c'est celle de
l'interdiction des nononictinoïdes vous
dites qu'il faut 3 ans d'adaptation or 3
ans avant rien n'a été fait est-ce que
vous l'avez constaté pour le coup il y a
une vraie responsabilité alors elle vous
incomble pas pour une partie quoi mais
mais s'il faut 3 ans pour sortir des
liquide et ben on aurait pu prendre la
décision 3 ans avant là il y a une
incurie publique incroyable on l'a dit
dans les débats si vous pouvez le
réaffirmer aujourd'hui euh on paye les
non décisions en terme d'anticipation
sur le PSN un des moyens importants de
faire non seulement la technosolution
don vous êtes très Friant mais de
l'agronomie c'est le PSN or le PSN que
vous proposez il est retoqué par la
Commission européenne il faut le réviser
il faut remettre un peu plus de verre et
cetera est-ce que vous avez des regrets
en la matière j'espère que vous pourrez
revenir et enfin sur le commerce
international vous êtes un expert sur
les questions de mesures miroir en quoi
P peuvent-elles être plus efficientes
qu'elles ne sont pour vraiment éviter
les concurrences déloyales c'est des
questions un peu j'espère qu'elles
pourront revenir à travers vos réponses
je doute pas une seconde que que les
collègues iront sur ce terrain là merci
sur ah pardon
oui alors bon vous avez l'habitude je
pense que vous avez noté les trois
questions du rapporteur je vais faire
l'économie de la parce qu'effectivement
il est déjà 17h40 je propose cela dit
que nous nous avons prévu de d'avoir
l'audition suivante à 18h je propose
qu'on se fix 18h10 pour laisser un peu
le temps à chacun de poser les questions
euh monsieur chassegne
oui ça ça a déjà été amorcé mais vous
avez commencz vos propos monsieur le
ministre cher Julien par affronter la
temporalité sur les alternatives je
crois qu'effectivement c'est la question
de fond c'est la question de fond je
donne un seul exemple je pour en donner
plusieurs j'ai en Limagne que vous
connaissez bien dans le puit d'omme des
agriculteurs des jeunes agriculteurs qui
par ailleurs sont conventionnés avec
limagrin qui travaillent sur
l'agriculture souscouvert je les ai
rencontré ils me disent il y a pas
possibilité de maintenir l'agriculture
souscouvert avec tout ce que ça peut
apporter au niveau environnemental je je
développe pas par rapport à ça si on n
pas un petit usage de glyphosate il y en
a même un qui a voulu aller plus loin
que les autres dans ce travail dans
cette évolution de de de pratique de
culturale et ben aujourd'hui il va
abandonner l'agriculture sous-couvert
parce qu'il est mangé par les herbes
c'est quand même un recul et c'est le
plus jeune d'entre eux donc c'est une
question j'ai rencontré l'été dernier un
viticulteur de Savoie qui me disait que
contenu des pintes qu'il peut avoir il
sera dans l'impossibilité de mécaniser
et que si on a interdit totalement le
glyphosate il arrêtera par contre
quelques semaines après en vos clus j'ai
discuté avec un autre viticulteur qui
lui est capable de régler le problème
avec des plantations différentes et tout
ça c'est dire qu'on a je crois et vous
l'avez dit avec des des mots autres que
moi une forme de de courage politique à
avoir qu'est-ce qu'on dit par rapport à
ça est-ce qu'on affronte au contraire on
a une position qui consiste à dire dès
le mois de janvier on arrête tout ça
globalement sans mesurer les
conséquences la deuxième chose c'est un
reproche que je voudrais vous faire
c'est un reproche voudraz vous faire
c'est avant de de quitter le le
gouvernement vous avez quand même mis la
main finale sur les écoorégimes sur les
plans stratégique nationale est ce qu'on
écoute dire depuis alors que vous étiez
un jeune ministre qu'on a beaucoup
apprécié par ailleurs enfin du moins ce
qui me concerne que vous avez fait un
plan stratégie naational de papa en
quelque sorte c'est-à-dire que sur les
écoorégimes vous avez pas eu le et c'est
pas facile le courage
politique de faire en sorte
qu'on encourage davantage ceux qui
évoluent avec l'agriculture qui aura des
conséquences bénéfiques pour
l'environnement et que pour servir tout
le monde pour pas déshabiller
quelques-uns et ben vous avez maintenu
le premier niveau des corégimes qui fait
qui fait que la totalité quasiment des
agriculteurs de notre pays ont droit ils
rentrent là-dedans et que ils vont
pas aller vers des difficultés pour
passer au stade supérieur parce que
l'encouragement ne sera pas suffisant
pour qu'il puisse passer au stade
supérieur au niveau de la
rentabilité c'est
tout monsieur le MIN je propose de
répondre à à chacun des membres de la
commission quant aux question du
rapporteur si vous pouvez en mêler des
réponses en fonction de la nature des
questions faites-le sinon on y viendra
avant de avant de clore la la séance je
vous laisse répondre monsieur merci
beaucoup je vais répondre au président
chassigne et et sur la première question
sur la temporalité glyphosate permettant
de répondre au rapporteur sur la
question des
néonicotinoïdes mais vous m'avez entendu
le dire le courage en politique c'est
d'affronter le temps le courage en
politique c'est de remettre de la raison
dans les débats c'est d'affronter la
complexité des choses et je crois que je
me suis évertué tout au long de mes 5
années au gouvernement à le faire je je
je crois pouvoir dire que je faisais
partie de ceux qui toujours rentrit dans
la complexité des choses et quand vous
prenez la nature c'est c'est c'est c'est
pas blanc ou noir d'ailleurs on dit bien
que dans la nature l'entropie est
positive ça veut dire que d'elle-même
elle crée la
complexité sur les nni effectivement la
loi est votée en 2016 quand je prends la
décision en 2020 enfin quand vous votez
la la disposition sur proposition du
gouvernement en
2020 les les les les fonds de recherche
ne sont pas établis c'est pour ça que ma
première action ma première action c'est
de mettre 7 millions d'euros sur la
table pour faire le pnri et que ma
première action qu'on faire ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur les instituts
de recherche c'est d'aligner tout le
monde en disant euh certains
euh enfin de manière certaine ces fonds
auraient dû être mis en place depuis
plus longtemps donc j'ai je je le dis
très clairement je l'ai toujours dit et
cetera sur le glyphosate euh Président
chassen je partage entièrement je me
souviens de passe d'armes que j'avais pu
avoir notamment avec le président
Mélenchon à l'époque là-dessus sur le
glyphosate j'ai je disais que la
complexité du glyphosate c'est qu'on a
deux ambitions environnementales qui
viennent se percuter d'un côté la
biodiversité de l'autre côté le carbone
pourquoi parce que l'agriculture
souscouvert
l'agriculture de
conservation moi j'ai été formé à ça
je je pense seul je je je réfléchis seul
je ma boussole c'est le seul donc le sol
il n'aime pas être labouré le sol il
préfère l'agriculture de conservation ou
souscouvert et cetera aujourd'hui on
déplais à certains et c'est malheureux
mais on n pas d'alternative crédiible à
cette agriculture de conservation sans
dsherbant et c'est un vrai sujet parce
que vous privilégiez quoi à la fin
l'impact de la biodive par le dsherbant
en surface où l'impact en terme de
carbone ou d'infiltration des eaux qu'
faire ce qui se passe en ce moment grâce
à la vie des verres de terre je rappelle
qu'un kg de verre de terre c'est 500 kg
de
vie et donc là aussi il faut investir
massivement sur le glyphosate moi j'ai
étudié beaucoup des alternatives
possibles je suis convaincu ça peut
paraître aberrant mais alors vraiment je
vous mets je je je je je vous mets au
Paris qu'un jour on se retrouvera
là-dessus
enfin je suis sûr qu'on est assez aligné
président chassen mais de manière
générale le le glyphosate aujourd'hui il
faut aller pour pas pardon les
désherbants pour maintenir l'agriculture
de conservation c'estd ne pas labourer
sans avoir à
dsherder vous avez certains qui ont
inventé des trucs du genre on électrifie
le champ on électrifie le champ comme ça
on va cramer les racines je vous laisse
imaginer la la tête des vers de terre
quand vous avez mis une anode d'un côté
une cathode de l'autre et vous avez
passé un courant entre les deux vous
avez des bandes intermédiaires pratiques
agronomique qui peuvent marcher mais
enfin c'est c'est c'est une pratique
agronomique moi je suis persuadé que la
solution viendra de la robotique mais
persuadé alors vous avez des beaux
esprits qui vous disent c'est trop bien
on a qu'à donner des binettes à plein de
gens ils vont aller biner le
champ messieurs les purs esprits ou
mesdam les pures esprits all les biner
les premiers si je peux dire dans les
champs
euh la robotique sera un des éléments et
donc tout ça ça nécessite de
l'investissement ce qu'on a fait dans le
cas de France 2030 je me suis battu à
fond à l'époque on disait mais pourquoi
il parle de robotique comme ça c'est
c'est génial la robotique faut le croire
c'est une partie intégrante de la 3ème
révolution agricole sur l'corégime
répondant ainsi au PSN du du rapporteur
sur les cororégime il y a toujours un
débat fondamental c'est est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous emportez la majorité
dans un mouvement dans une accélération
du mouvement parce que la majorité est
déjà en mouvement mais est-ce que vous
emportez la majorité dans une
accélération du mouvement ou est-ce que
vous vous vous met vous emportez plus
rapidement mais mais de manière beaucoup
moins inclusive moi j'estime que les
corrégimes on a essayé de faire des des
de faire cette dynamique collégiale
ortant parce que dans les corrégimes
alors c'est très technique mais euh
c'est ces systèmes de points qui se
fondent notamment sur la la diversité la
rotation des cultures entre autres mais
enfin plein d'autres sujet dans ce beau
territoire d'élevage que vous appréciez
tant on a beaucoup travaillé également
alors c'est pas les cororégimes c'est
d'autres pilier de la PAC sur
l'accompagnement des des éleveurs mais
fondamentalement pour résumer mon mon
point c'est est-ce que on est-ce qu'on
embarque le plus grand
nombre et et dans ce cas-là ben pour
embarquer le plus grand nombre il faut
faire des ambitions palié par Pali
allier oou est-ce qu'on se dit bah en
fait c'est hyper simple on va mettre
euh des choses hyper hyper hyper hyper
ambitieuses mais on sait qu'on va en
laisser beaucoup de côté euh je rappelle
parce que cette assemblée aime beaucoup
le débat sur les aides conditionnées
comme tous les Français d'ailleurs je je
ne connais pas de secteur que le secteur
agricole où les aides publiques fustell
national ou européennne sont autant
conditionné que le domaine agricole hein
je je n'ai pas d'autres secteurs en tête
donc là on parle des des de l'ajoute des
conditions conditions et cetera enfin
sur les politiques européennes moi je
suis convaincu d'une chose c'est que
maintenant faut enfin je l'ai défendu
autant que faire se peut si on veut
aller plus vite si on veut aller plus
vite il faut juste qu'on ait une
cohérence globale entre la politique
interne européenne sur les transitions
et la politique externe européenne je
veux dire c'est c'est ces clauses miroir
c'est c'est un fait c'est passé un peu
sous silence mais en vrai qui était un
énorme message que le le jour de où je
prends la présidence du Conseil européen
c'est le jour le 1er janvier 2022 c'est
le jour où la Commission européenne est
censé mettre en place des clauses miroir
voté démocratiquement par le Parlement
européen adopté démocratiquement par le
deè colégislateur c'est le Conseil
européen sur les antibiotiques de
croissance dans les élevages Commission
européenne ne l'avait toujours pas prise
la veille l'avant-veille l'avant
l'avant-veille le surlendemain non plus
alors que je suis président du Conseil
européen je prends un décret qui
interdit l'importation de viande avec
des antibiotiques de croissance quand
j'appelle antibiotiques de croissance
c'est des antibiotiques dans les
élevages pour éviter que des maladies se
propagent parce qu'un telle densité on
les protège préventivement là où en
Europe on a le droit d'utiliser des
antibio que pour soigner des animaux
malades eux il les
bourrent et je prends un décret mon
décret il est
illégal parce que c'est une compétence
européenne et je suis président du
conseil européen à ce moment-là je le
prends quand même en disant à la
Commission européenne c'est pas possible
et je me souviens même en conférence de
presse devant le commissaire parce que
faut c'est trop facile de CR critiquer
l'Europe en France et d'être hyper sympa
quand on est à Bruxelles mie vaut
soutenir l'Europe dans laquelle on croit
et dire les choses véritablement à
Bruxelles et à Bruxelles en conférence
de presse devant le commissaire à mes
côtés je dis je président du conseil je
dis l'Europe fait un un dénis de
démocratie sur cette question puisque
les choses avaient été voté donc les
clauses les clauses miroir et je suis je
je suis libéral dans l'âme je crois au
commerce international je non vous savez
bien que si si j'étais pas en marche je
serai communiste au Président chassen
vous le savez mais mais mais évidemment
que évidemment qu'il faut avoir le
courage d'affronter ces règles de
commerce internationales on ne peut pas
demander d'aller beaucoup plus vite à
ceux qui nous nourrissent en France qui
font plein d'efforts et cetera alors
quand même même temps on laisse rentrer
des produits qui mais j'ai des dizaines
d'exemples le le le poulet le poulet
alors je veux pas faire du du dénoncer
mais de nos amis mais le poulet
brésilien je je je raconter la
conviction la plus profonde en plus qu
je vis il s'avère que j'ai vécu en
Égypte je travaillais là-bas un jour
j'ai mon aîné d'enfant qui est malade je
demande à maNounou je viens d'arriver en
Égypte le médecin me prédit des
antibiotiques je demande à maNounou mais
euh est-ce que vous connaissez la nounou
de ma jeune fille est-ce que vous
connaissez un pharmacien nounou me
répond non mais oui vous pouvez aller au
supermarché à côté mais non je dois
acheter des antibiotiques acheter du
poulet c'était du poulet brésilien vous
aviez les protéines et la moxyinine en
même temps on est en 2009 et ça moi je
l'ai toujours regardé toujours donc je
me suis dit c'est close aujourd'hui 50 %
du poulet qu'on mange en France il est
importé de pays où on peut faire des des
antibiotiques de croissance et donc
quand je prends ce délai illégal quand
vous votez quand vous votez à ma demande
le fait de dire que maintenant euh dans
toute la restauration hors domicile faut
indiquer l'origine des viandes au-delà
de la viande de bœuf mais du poulet et
cetera et cetera parce que dans les
supermarchés c'est la viande française
le plus souvent dans dans les les
productions hors domicile ou ultra
transformé il faut regarder l'origine il
faut regarder l'origine dans les écoles
faut regarder l'origine maintenant c'est
la loi impose d'un de mettre cette
origine voilà vous avez au fond de mon
expérience qui fait que c'est close
miroir moi j'y crois à fond parce que si
vous faites pas ça sur le poulet enfin
sur les clos miroir avec le poulet sur
les clos miroirs
avec
la la noisette avec la moutarde et
l'Europe parfois le fait on l'a fait sur
le dimétoat avec les is turque
heureusement mais c'était d'abord la
France qui l'a fait ensuite l'Europe et
voilà donc il faut c'est c'est normal ce
qu'on ne peut pas ce qu'on a pas le
droit de produire sur notre pays on doit
avoir le courage de dire qu'on peut pas
l'importer comme si de rien
n'était merci Monsieur le Ministre on va
devoir accélérer pour laisser le temps
quand même au il y a encore trois
personnes qui ont des questions à vous
poser donc que je vous demander de
raccourcir vos interventions euh quatre
personnes on va prendre deux questions
par deux questions madame thin puis
monsieur de
fournasse merci euh monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
voulais vous interroger sur sur quelques
thématiques et rebondir sur certains
thèmes qui ont qui ont parfois été
abordé un premier qui est une question
qui revient souvent lors de nos
auditions c'est celui de la protection
de la qualité de notre
eau je sais que durant euh votre passage
au ministère vous vous êtes concentré
sur les questions d'accès à l'eau pour
les exploitations agricoles
et je voulais connaître votre vision des
enjeux de la préservation de la qualité
de l'eau euh lorsque cette ressource
cohabite avec certains usages agricoles
notamment l'usage des produits
phytosanitaires et euh bien évidemment
au regard des des rapports scientifiques
nombreux qui aujourd'hui euh euh nous
éclairent sur cette question je voulais
connaître votre sentiment euh d'autre
part je voulais euh aussi vous
interroger sur votre soutien à la
filière bio
hier midi manifesté devant l'Assemblée
nationale plusieurs collectifs
d'agriculteurs demandant une
augmentation des moyens consacré à la
filière bio et aux mesures
agroécologiques et
climatiqu pourquoi l'État n'a pas tenu
en la matière ses engagements financiers
puisque l'enveloppe qui est allouée à
cmaec est aujourd'hui fortement réduite
ne pensez-vous pas que pour être à la
hauteur des ambitions environnementales
dont nous parlons depuis le début de
cette aud il faut consolider au côté des
collectivités l'accompagnement de ces
transitions et en particulier auprès de
ces
agriculteurs enfin j'ai j'ai j'ai deux
autres thématiques sur lesquelles je
souhaite vous interroger très
simplement sur la question des lobby
vous nous avez tout à
l'heure expliqué que dans votre méthode
vous partiez des constats la méthode les
visions lorsque vous étiez ministre
comment était contre ô la résilience de
votre cabinet et de votre administration
aux tentatives d'influence
particulièrement en matière de pesticide
en clair avvez-vous une vision en la
matière pour résister aux influences de
de certains lobby et puis dernier point
vous avez tout à l'heure beaucoup
évoqué et bien un un principe important
celui de de de de la décision politique
comment la positionner euh au cœur de de
de divers arbitrages je voulais vous
réinterroger plus précisément euh sur
votre position au sein des arbitrages
interministériels euh lorsque vous étiez
ministre quels arbitrages avez-vous
gagné au sein du gouvernement notamment
en matière de réduction de l'usage des
produits phytosanitaires et comment
avez-vous travaillé au côté de d'autres
ministères euh notamment lorsque la
ministre de la santé était présente tout
à l'heure enfin en tout cas la ministre
agès firmain le baudau elle a évoqué euh
une difficulté à pouvoir cohabiter avec
d'autres ministères en particulier celui
de l'agriculture mais aussi de
l'environnement de l'industrie avec
Bercy aussi donc comment avez-vous
cohabité quelle place avez-vous donné au
ministère de l'agriculture au sein des
politiques interministériel sur ces
questions des produits phytosanitaires
je vous
remercie merci chers collègues monsieur
le
fourourasse merci monsieur le Président
j'avais plusieurs questions mais vu les
les 11 minutes qui restent jeis je vais
me concentrer sur une seule qui qui qui
c'est c'est je relance monsieur le
ministre sur sur la question des clauses
miroirs on a on a moi j'ai suivi
l'épisode de la présidence du Conseil
européen j'étais pas député donc j'ai
suivi ça de loin mais il faut quand même
reconnaître que vous avez porté ce sujet
euh assez fort euh mais on a pu voir
dans les dans les auditions diverses et
variées que qu'on qu'on a réalisé avec
cette commission d'enquête notamment
députés européens que qui y a beaucoup
de frein à ces Claus miroir d'abord la
prise de conscience vous vous l'avez
porté d'autres mouvements politiques
l'avz l'avz porté avant vous mais enfin
vous vous avez le mérite de de de le
porter en tant que ministre mais on on
apprend que au sein du Conseil européen
apparemment la France est assz isolé sur
le sujet et puis surtout c'est la mise
en place pratique qui qui est compliquée
comment on fait pour contrôler des modes
de production dans des pays vous avez
cité le Brésil par exemple et et et ma
question est simple c'est c'est euh vous
avez donc porté ce sujet avec avec
conviction encore une fois mais à partir
du moment où on connaît tous les freins
qu'il y a à sa mise en place pratique
euh est-ce qui est-ce qui est-ce qu'il a
pas eu un quelque part un manque de
sincérité dans dans dans ce combat c'est
c'est c'estent une question ouverte que
que je porte d'autant plus
que on voit de la part du gouvernement
actuelle si vous voulez euh ce discours
qui revient à dire on va restreindre des
moyens de production mais vous inquiétez
pas il y a des closuses miroir sauf que
les clos miroir non seulement elles sont
pas pas mis en place mais on sa on voit
pas très bien comment elles vont
l'être merci cher collèg Monsieur le
Ministre
euh madame la députée beaucoup beaucoup
de questions euh sur sur la question de
l'eau euh c'est une question absolument
essentiel euh quand quand je prends mes
fonctions je demande euh mes directeurs
et directrices d'administration combien
y y a-t-il de personnes qui s'occupent
de l'eau au ministère ministère c'est
30000 personnes 15000 sur l'enseignement
agricole 15000 sur les fonctions du
ministère autre que l'enseignement
agricole et d'ailleurs ça me permet de
saluer ce trésor qu l'enseignement
agricole on me répond il y a 5
personnes C personnes sur donc 15000
audelà de l'enseignement agricole euh
parce que toute la gestion de l'eau euh
a été euh transféré en terme de
compétenence au ministère de
l'Environnement et d'ailleurs moi je
vois très bien quand je suis diplômé des
Eaux et Forêts en 2004 euh tous ceux qui
dans ma promotion avaient fait la
compétence ha partaient au ministère de
l'Environnement et pas du tout au
ministère de l'Agriculture sujet au
combien complexe parce que quand vous
avez comme l'un des principaux défis des
années à venir pour un ministère la
question de l'eau et vous n'avez que
cinq personnes euh qui ont euh euh
ce savoir vous pose un alors peut-être
était-il un tout petit peu plus que CIN
mais si vous voyez ce que je veux dire
très peu c'est pour ça que je lance
cette grande
initiative avec Beranger Raba la
secrétaire d'État et la ministre Barbara
pompil du varen de l'eau et du
changement climatique qui pour moi est
un élément incroyablement
structurant de de tout cela c'est là où
on évoque les sujets de de captation
d'eau c'est là où on évoque les sujets
des système et de et de protection c'est
pour moi vraiment l'équilibre qu'on a
développé dans le varen et pour moi le
bon équilibre à avoir euh je pourrais en
parler des heures et rentrer dans les
dans les détails mais mais mais je pense
véritablement que d'ailleurs j'invite
aussi le le rapport transpartisan du
Sénat sur ce sujet et est très
intéressant le deuxième élément sur la
protection de l'eau on on a eu à à à
revoir et à mettre en œuvre les
différentes directives
Nitrat également là aussi sujet
évidemment essentiel au niveau national
également au niveau européen parce qu'on
voit que tout le monde ne n'applique pas
de la même manière si je puux dire ces
directives au niveau européen impliquant
un certain nombre de concurrence déloyal
au sein du au sein du marché commun euh
sur la question de la filer bio
euh je je je n'ai pas la la enfin je me
permets je de de vous corriger en tout
cas
euh sur le budget que moi je portais je
ne sais pas j'ai aucun chiffre sur ce
qui est fait aujourd'hui mais dans le la
revue de la pque sur les MAEC euh on n'
pas réduit sur les MAEC le montant de la
bio c'est c'est c'est pas vrai on a eu
un débat la somme d'ailleurs total qu'on
qu'on octroyait était en augmentation
quand vous preniez toutes les
différentes lignes il y a eu un énorme
débat à l'époque qui était sur les aides
au maintien ou les aides à
l'installation le débat portait sur ça
jusqu'à à présent on avait des aides au
maintien l'aide à l'installation et là
on avait mis le paquet sur les aides à
l'installation montant global de de
l'aide au bio et singulièrement des des
des des
Maek des ma qu'on les avait pas mis en
en réduction pas du tout était même de
mémoire en augmentation maintenant sur
la question du bio de la HVE de
l'agriculture de conservation de
l'agriculture protectrice des et cetera
de de de toutes les mesures
agroécologie que je défends toutes dans
leur nature différente avec énormément
de de de force je je suis un fervant
défenseur du bio je suis aussi un
fervant défenseur d'agriculture de
conservation vous l'aurez compris mais
l'un n'exclut pas l'autre bien au
contraire sur tous ces sujets là il y a
les aides de l'État il y a la question
et aujourd'hui on voit à quel point on
est confronté il y a la question de de
la répercuion enfin du juste coût et du
juste
prix qui est der derrière en période
d'inflationist c'est d'autant plus
compliqué qu' faire ce que je disais en
introduction moi je pense que l'élément
essentiel et ça je j'en suis convaincu
et et j'ai été ministre de la Ville j'ai
j'ai passé énormément de temps à
travailler au côté de ceux qui qui
accompagnent les plus fragiles je suis
convaincu d'une chose c'est que ça ne
peut pas être le compte des résultats
des agriculteurs qui finance les
politiques sociales de notre pays
c'est-à-dire que il faut accepter par
des PO ti économique forte de soutenir
le bio le HVE l'agriculture de
conservation nos agriculteurs de manière
générale il faut des politique sociale
en parallèle qui viennent soutenir nos
concitoyens les plus fragiles face au
coup de l'alimentation mais le la guerre
des prix qui a été faite soutenue
politiquement pas par la majorité à
laquelle j'ai appartenu au contraire on
a tout fait pour l'éviter mais de
manière précédente au motif du pouvoir
d'achat des Français est à mes yeux une
erreur parce que ça n'est pas au compte
de résultat des agriculteurs de le
financer et c'est une vraie question de
de de une vraie question de je je visais
pas je je Visz pas votre majorité
monsieur le rapporteur vis
éz non je crois qu'il était avant il
était après il avait été le le poste
agricole après enfin c'est pas lui
c'était le ministre de l'économie de
l'époque qui avait porté la chose je
pense à la loi LME pour être clair euh
sur les lobby à la fin moi les décisions
ce que je disais au rapporteur tout à
l'heure les décisions je les ai prise
moi j'assume toutes les décisions le
lobby je pense qu'il faut que vous
différenciez les cabinets de lobby en
qui et pour qui je ne porte aucune
espèce
d'estime des syndicats les les syndicats
parce que souvent dans le débat on
appelle les syndicats agricoles des
lobby les syndicats agricoles sont des
syndicats des syndicat il y en a des
majoritaires il y en a des minoritaires
mais enfin ce sont des syndicats des
syndicats de de de des agriculteurs et
ces syndicats heureusement que le
ministre les reçoit et heureusement que
le ministre travaille avec eux les
recevoir travailler avec eux ne veut pas
dire faire ce qu'il veulent mais enfin
heureusement qu'on est qu'on qu'on
travaille et je vais vous dire c'est
même une chance dans le milieu agricole
d'avoir un milieu aussi syndiqué qui
n'existe nulle part ailleurs moi moi qui
crois beaucoup dans le dialogue social
je c'est une chance de pouvoir travaille
avec des syndicats parfois on est
d'accord parfois on n'est pas d'accord
parfois vous avez des visions qui se
rejoignent parfois vous avez des visions
qui se rejoignent pas mais heureusement
qu'on travaille avec les les syndicats
je ne serai jamais de ceux qui
considèrent qu'un syndicat euh enfin de
confondre des syndicats avec les
cabinets de lobby voilà et à la fin
c'est les décisions c'est moi qui les
qui les prenait bon par ailleurs j'ai
j'ai j'ai qui plusis c'est enfin
généralement sur les sujets agricoles je
savais à peu près de quoi je parlais
étant moi-même fort foré sur ces sujets
et une vraie expérience dessus donc
j'avais pas besoin qu'on me dise ce
qu'il fallait faire je je j'assume les
décisions et je les prenais moi sur la
position politique sur les arbitrages
alors vous faire la liste de tous les
arbitrages émis en mon sens ou autre
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que tout les arbitrages qui nous ont
conduit à financer massivement euh cette
3è révolution agricole ce temps des
transitions et cetera était pour moi
absolument essentiel et et et vis-à-vis
du travail avec les autres ministères
moi j'ai toujours beaucoup enfin je suis
plutôt quelqu'un qui travaille avec les
autres que qui travaill seul dans mon
couloir de
nage et je pense que le travail avec le
ministère de la Santé est absolument
essentiel n pardonnez-moi je vais vous
demander juste d'accélérer dans ma
réponse parce qu'en fait il y a
encoreoués et il faut aborder la
question DEC clause miroir et je
voudrais quand même laisser la parole à
Monsieur Mar et Monsieur en TR TR 3
secondes enfin en 2 minutes pour
Monsieur le Député sur la mise en
pratique des closes miroirs je je suis
pas du tout tout d'accord avec vous
alors surtout quand vous dites que on
porte des choses qui soient pas sincères
là aussi c'est c'est c'est c'est
vraiment pas ma façon de faire je vous
donne juste des exemples la
déforestation c'est la France qui a
porté le règlement sur la lutte contre
la déforestation orté aujourd'hui par
l'origine enfin par ce qu'on appelle les
politiques d'origine et par les
politiques de traçage vous pouvez le
faire je dis pas que c'est toujours
facile mais vous pouvez le faire vous
avez même des solutions je peux vous les
je peux vous les transmettre et les
passer pour pour y parvenir sur les
politiques d'élevage sur les clos
miroirs avec des antibiotiques pareil
aujourd'hui en France dans n'importe
quel dans n'importe quelle boucherie
vous vous pouvez savoir le morceau
appartient à quel vage dans quel élevage
et dans l'élevage vous savez exactement
la liste des produits qui ont été
utilisés donc le traage l'origine c'est
quelque chose qui est tout à fait
possible et d'ailleurs je note que à la
fois les fédération par exemple la
Fédération bovine des associations je
salue vraiment le travail fait par la
FNB sur le sujet des Claus miroir de
manière extrêmement ouverte d'ailleurs
ils l'ont fait avec des S tank et avec
des des associations
environnemental sur ce travail des
clauses miroir et tout le monde sait
exactement que c'est c'est ce qu'on a
poussé ce qu'on a voté ce qu'on a adopté
et ce vers quoi il faut aller c'est tout
à fait tout à fait
applicable
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
fugit monsieur Martino je crois que
madameelle sur la clause miroire si vous
avez un point à rajouter vous vous le
ferez monsieur fugit puis monsieur
Martino merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre c'est
cher Julien c'est un plaisir de de vous
retrouver ici c'est aussi un plaisir
parce que vous avez laissé je le dis
très clairement un très bon souvenir
dans la profession agricole et je dirais
même ce qui concerne ma circonscription
en tout cas de toute obédience possible
agricole donc voilà et je je tenais à je
tenais aussi à à le rappeler euh vous
avez déjà répondu à de nombreuses
questions moi j'aimerais bien revenir
sur sur une des réflexions que vous avez
partagé avec nous euh notamment autour
j'appellerai moi le le mieux nourrir le
mieux produire et euh vous avez évoqué
l'idée que ce qui fondait un peu votre
action c'était la référence à une
question de justice et aussi de science
et à travers un sujet qui a été abordé
tout à l'heure et qui tou d'actualité
qu'on a encore débattu récemment dans
cette cette assemblée la question du du
glyphosate euh j'ai bien aimé
l'intervention de mon collègue André
chassigne permettrait de lui faire
remarquer que que tout ça c'était déjà
dans le rapport de 2020 que j'avais fait
avec Jean-Baptiste Morau comme quoi
l'agriculture conservation des sols sans
un peu de glyphosate il suffit d'aller
bêcher des sols tout simplement se
rendre compte
enfin on voit bien qu'on a une véritable
problématique je pense de de culture
scientifique vous avez dit aussi aussi
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre au fond
que vous étiez surpris que les
agriculteurs ne fassent pas beaucoup
référence aux instituts de recherche et
cetera moi j'aimerais avoir votre vision
sur avec du recul quelle analyse en fait
vous et et et surtout d'après vous
comment y remédier et est-ce que
irremédier ça passe entre autres par euh
la formation La formation de les lycées
est-ce que c'est pas une formation m
plus global qu'il faut avoir sur la
culture scientifique dans dans notre
pays euh qui nous manque de mon point de
vue alors le l'ingénieur chimiste que je
suis pense qu'on manque de cultur
scientifique mais peut-être que vous
vous avez une autre vision et vous avez
aussi évoqué tout à l'heure que il
fallait avoir toujours une vision
globale un petit peu transversale si
j'ai bien compris notamment que vous
avez évoqué entre autres la question des
closes miroir et ça m'intéresse donc
d'avoir votre là aussi votre votre
vision de comment on fait concrètement
si on veut arriver à à la fois dans
notre société et au niveau de l'Europe
faire en sorte que que tous ces enjeux
on puisse les débattre de manière assez
dépassionnée et qu'on puisse se baser
sur la science et non pas sur des
croyances et on a récemment débattu sur
une proposition de résolution européenne
sur la question du glyphosate où moi je
me suis investi et j'ai entendu des
choses qui m'ont assez étonné
et qui était vraiment basé beaucoup sur
la croyance et absolument pas sur la
science il était quasiment impossible
d'évoquer même ici dans ces cette
enceinte euh donc des des des sujets
tels que l'agriculture et conservation
des sols un exemple concret voilà donc
j'aimerais bien avoir votre votre votre
vision d'autant que vous avez pris un
petit peu de recul et peut-être que
c'est encore mieux quand on est déporté
qu' l'on porte en regard sur l'action
qu'on a pu conduire ensemble il fut un
temps merci merci chers collègue
monsieur Martino merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le ministre
pour votre
exposé
justement vousz quand vous avez parlé de
cette capacité de produire protéger
notre agriculture et notre alimentation
est-ce que et pour compléter les les di
de de de mes collègues précédents pardon
le est-ce que justement on quelquefois
on fait pas fausse route parce que
autant on sait très bien qu'on va
utiliser des des produits pour les
herbicides mais on aura donc de la
robotique sur les insecticides on sait
très bien qu'on pourra les remplacer
justement en se servant des bons
insectes mais la vraie problématique est
celle queon utilise bien souvent dans
nos vergers dans nos cultures c'est face
aux maladies les champignons comment on
va faire euh sans pesticides là je je
alors je ne suis pas scientifique mais
je me pose vraiment justement beaucoup
de questions comment on peut et donc
est-ce que ce n'est pas de essayer de
faire croire qu' au enfin à la grande à
la grande à tout le monde que l'on peut
faire autrement sur les sur sur sur les
maladies j'ai j'ai vraiment un un
sérieux doute voilà et je vous remercie
d'avoir justement parlé avec Madame
Thomin donc justement de d'économie
parce que le vrai sujet à la fin c'est
justement est-ce que ce n'est pas
justement de euh
de permettre une alimentation saine à la
majorité des gens et donc mais aussi
accessible à tous et donc oui au close
miroir parce que si on interdit quelque
chose chez nous il faut pas qu'on puisse
je veux dire au moins l'importer mais
comment on fait pour justement permettre
à tout le monde de de manger avec pas
forcément des des moyens très élevés je
vous remercie merci chers collègues
monsieur je vais vous demander d'essayer
d'être le plus
possible le plus rapidement possible
j'ai j'ai monsieur le député Fuji la
formation oui archi oui mais d'ailleurs
les agriculteurs les agriculteurs pardon
français sont je crois ne pas dire de
bêtises les plus diplômés d'Europe
euh la formation elle elle elle est elle
est absolument essentielle je pense le
deuxième point c'est pour créer ce
rapprochement entre institut qui soit
public ou privé et agriculteur je pense
qu'il faut se mettre d'accord sur le
chemin c'estàd quels sont les priorités
comment les les avancer et comment les
déployer je pense que c'est ce chemin en
commun et c'est ça que j'ai essayé de
faire et encore une fois dans mes propos
qu' soi pas mal compris vis-à-vis de
l'ineray j'ai c'est une chance
extraordinaire qu'on a l'ineray on a les
meilleurs
chercheurs ils font un boulot incroyable
je dis juste que c'est important que les
publics le privé enfin un situ public
instit privé et monde agricole tout le
monde soit bien aligné sur le chemin
pour que un moment donné on se dise pas
c'est trop ce que vous avez trouvé sur
tel sujet mais enfin c'est pas le sujet
auquel euh enfin que que solution pardon
que ce soit problème qui cherche
solution et pas solution qui cherche
problème à la fin si je pense c'est très
important sur la science et la
complexité j'y reviens pas c'est c'est
vraiment un il faut lutter de toutes nos
forces contre le simplisme
contre le côté binaire des choses il
faut accepter cette complexité et
d'ailleurs je pense que il faut que les
politiques soient les les meilleurs
exemples de la chose je suis pas sûr que
ce soit toujours le le cas et si j'ai pu
le constater puisque vous me demandez
mon regard externe j'ai j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit beaucoup
amélioré dans les dépAts que je peux
regarder depuis ma télévision sur ce qui
se passe dans l'hémicycle en terme de
d'appréhension de la complexité des
choses si si vous voyez ce que je veux
dire
euh monsieur le député Martino sur la
politique sociale ce que je vou je
voulais dire c'est que je pense qu'il
faut différencier ce qui relève d'une
politique économique et d'une politique
sociale la politique économique elle
doit permettre la production elle doit
permettre la production tout en
permettant la protection
environnementale c'est-à-dire qu'elle
doit permettre l'inclusion de cette
valeur de la protection de
l'environnement dans les prix cette
politique économique elle doit empêcher
les rentes de se former qu'on faire tout
ce que nous avons pu faire avec le
président et vraiment je permettez-moi
de le saluer aussi amicalement que que
de de manière reconnaissante dans le
cadre de la loi égalim d'ailleurs
monsieur président chassen certains
disaient que cette loi égalim 2
descrosaill était était quasiment une
loi communiste comme quoi je suis
vraiment pas si loigné de ça de vous
monsieur le Président chassigne et et
parce que je pense que ces politiques
économiques doivent éviter les les
rentes en revanche elles ne peuvent pas
se substituer à une politique sociale
c'est encore une fois le compte de
résultat des agriculteurs peut pas
financer le pouvoir d'achat des Français
ou ou ou à la fin ça se fini par un
accroissement des importations et c'est
ce qui est en train de enfin ce qui
s'est passé durant les derniers
décennies et ce sur quoi j'ai essayé de
lutter sur la production et
l'anticipation et les champignons que
vous donnez c'est dans la vie dans la la
vigne juste un exemple qui est
passionnant c'est l'histoire de Monsieur
Bousquet en en 10 secondes monsieur le
Président Monsieur Bousquet c'est celui
qui a qui a consacré sa vie à lutter
contre
l'odium dans les cultures de de vigne il
a trouvé il a eu l'idée géniale de
croiser des vignes américaines avec des
vignes européennes parce que les vignes
américaines se protégeent naturellement
contre l' podium il a fait ça pendant à
peu près 20 ans puis il s'est rendu
compte qu'il y avait que un gène qui
avait été modifié donc c'était pas
suffisant donc linra prend le relais ils
font tout un programme bref au bout de
40 ans il trouent euh la solution
monsieur Bousquet était mort
entre-temps et aujourd'hui elles sont
inscrites au au fameux catalogue et
c'est là où le temps des transitions est
parfois hyper long et moi j'espère que
les nouvelles techniques notamment les
fameuses NBT dont on n pas discuté ce
soir mais qui mérite d'être discuté
qu'il faut évidemment encadrer et cetera
mais il faut que la science nous
permette d'accélérer le temps et de
faire donc face au temps de l'impatience
et je partage ce temps de l'impatience
mais peut-être que le temps de la
science si on lui permet d'accélérer les
choses permettra de faire face au temps
de l'impatience en tout cas cette
gestion du temps est tellement vrai en
agriculture euh mais mais c'est un vrai
sujet en en politique aussi il faut il
faut la complexité du temps doit être
appréhendée c'est une certitude
j'ai essayé d'être rapide merci Monsieur
le Ministre merci de vous être déplacé
d'avoir pris ce temps justement de
répondre à nos questions ce temps
d'échange avec avec la commission